greets everyone I'm Alana and today
we're making a video about a very
important topic this is something that
every young woman and man has to go
through eventually and that is figuring
out how to send the most flattering
nudes there are so many things to think
of when taking nudes like lighting what
kind of angle you want and most
importantly is the person that you're
sending them to what kind of nudes do
they like now of course step one has to
be all about the circumstance did you
just get a fuck-boy on Instagram sending
you a message saying a baby girl wants
some [ __ ] send nudes did they get
creative and send some kind of meme that
implied that they wanted a nude or is it
your significant other and they're
finally asking you for the first time to
send the nudes all totally different
contexts that call for different kinds
of nudes many different people certainly
do like them in different ways so let's
talk about it step by step first things
first you really need to make sure that
the other person actually wants to
receive a nude from you sending notes at
random is a really terrible idea if you
have received a dick pic in your time
don't stress I did make a dick pic
survivors guy that's already up on this
channel but consent is the first thing
send notes to people who want them from
you especially to people who've asked
second is analyzing the profile of the
fuck-boy if you take a good look through
his Instagram feed you might be able to
find out what kind of things he's
interested in are there are a lot of
recurring themes in his photos does he
seem like a bad boy or more of a good
guy how many photos does he have where
he's wearing a fedora these are all
things that factor into taking the
perfect personal nude now it's your turn
one of my favorite things to do is
Google for different kinds of nudes to
really get me inspired and find things
that I like that I might be interested
in sharing browsing for nudes just on
Google Images will give you a bunch of
different results and some really
inspiring stuff so your last step before
you send it off that nude is to take
them use the inspiration that you've
found from the person's social media
account and what you know about them as
well as the inspiration you've found on
Google to source your own news honestly
it's all about feeling comfortable and
happy it doesn't really matter where you
take
more what angle you take them from the
most important part is that you're happy
with the notes that you've taken and
with these few simple steps I'm sure the
person that you're sending them to will
be just as happy with the results go
[ __ ] yourself you stupid [ __ ] I don't
understand what went wrong